we decided to give this resale to all
the MLB fans out there who have been
watching the show purely just for this
guy right here we want to say thank you
because we recognize that they're the
reason that we're here and we hope that
they will rally behind us one more time
and help us win that Mirrorball trophy
Lindsey Arnold and David Ross previewing
their Dancing with the Stars finale
routines only with ET it's a fun dance
we've got baseball bats in it and it's
gonna be a good time so I'm excited and
you know to that you being the first
baseball player over on the show if /
when you win you will be the first
baseball player to win Dancing with
Stars how does it feel to make history I
can't even wrap my brain around winning
this competition my biggest goal is to
win for her more than anything else I
want to I want to let her get that
Mirrorball trophy and take it home and
my daughter's already told me it's going
in her room if we win one thing I've
learned is that I don't think you can
predict this show right I definitely
don't think I expected to be here and
you know Nnamani and and Rashad are both
great dancers so who knows who knows
what the fans are thinking I'm just
happy that we're all a tight-knit group
and a real family and I'm rooting for
everybody honestly I think I'm rooting
for them poor Finn me he is that bad to
say I'm sorry
you